and you know so many businesses were
closed during the pandemic
uh and but the ones that were essential
of course
had to find a way to stay open and do
business safely
and herrera family dental is one of
those businesses
and they were hit pretty hard during the
pandemic
but herrera family dental was actually
founded by a local las vegas
who was born and raised here and she
gave
back to her community and she decided
that she was going to invest
she grew up here her parents speaking
spanish and they had to take care of
their patients
and so many others who were afraid to go
anywhere during the pandemic
dr evelyn herrera worked hard to realize
her dream of being a dentist
her private practice in sunrise manor
was open barely a year when the pandemic
forced her to close
we've always been trained to deal with
infectious diseases but i think
the unknown was more scarier than
anything and she worried for her
patients
their oral health so how long were we
going to not be able to see patients
because
they still need to be able to take care
of the oral health dr herrera was forced
to furlough
all but one staff assistant left to
cover phones and help her with emergency
cases
patients who truly couldn't wait for
covid to be over i was in excruciating
pain my
tooth decided it wanted to hurt it was
march right at the very beginning gloria
long hernandez
has been a loyal patient for five years
seeing dr herrera in various dentist
offices
and now here at herrera family dental on
lamb and charleston
both share roots of growing up in east
las vegas when she started she told me
i want to help my community she says i'm
going to be a dentist not because i want
to you know she wasn't looking to be
wealthy she wasn't looking for all these
other things she was literally looking
to help the community evelyn herrera's
first language is spanish
her hard-working parents immigrated from
mexico and made school a priority for
their kids
she received scholarships for college
then took out loans to attend unlv
dental school
and with support from her husband and
daughter she
sacrificed to create a successful
practice i know some people think that
it's a rough area
but it's only because it's a little bit
older but we do have a lot of culture
in this community it would be nice and
this is one of the reasons why i came
back it would be nice to see more
businesses pop up herrera family dental
is open again with staff and coveted
safety restrictions still in place
i couldn't have felt more comfortable at
a time when everything was very
uncomfortable i think we did a lot for
their patients and i think they
definitely did appreciate it because a
lot of them still come here and dr
herrera hopes it's the beginning of a
very long relationship
with sunrise manor residents i want to
be that dentist that grows up with the
families that
how i saw my own personal dentist on the
east side
well dr herrera has invested a lot to be
there now 80 percent of her patients
speak spanish only and she said a lot of
the patients there
well maybe not a lot but there are still
quite a few patients that are
still afraid to even come back and so
she's going to be very patient with her
patients
and give them time to come back she
wants them to feel comfortable but
she says she's really happy that she and
her one staff member who we heard from
their alina were able to see
the ones that had emergencies true
emergencies
to keep them out of the er when the
hospitals were so crowded with coveted
patients
and so she felt like she was able to do
her part so
dr herrera is a true success story here
in the east valley one of many
eastsiders
that are giving back to their community